I have empathy for like kids and animals
oh okay that's nice it's my startup it's
a starter kit it's something that's
that's a step in the right direction oh
I'm sorry
you know what I'm old enough to I'll
never satisfy you
happen in the right direction say that
that is what uh uh separate you from say
a sociopath the serial killers that you
care about animals you care about
children so that's that's good that's
good news for you today because I've
taken those polls you haven't seen
Deadpool are you a serial killer yes I
have taken that test it's not gone well
yeah exactly after the fourth question
you're like all right
do you laugh am I a misery of others
I think we got that one if it's on TV
and I don't like look I don't
trying to think of something uh yeah no
I think I do
every time I saw that guy wipe out on
his scooter oh it was amazing he's this
older guy
well that's always funny though falling
people funny wait an older man was on a
what he's on a scooter he's on his
scooter he was riding like a Harley and
he like he came whipping out it was one
of those I was on the other side of the
road and there was this concrete divider
and he he just he was going too fast and
he couldn't make the turn and he hit the
the the concrete thing and he High sided
and went like up and over just like
landed and just slid on his face
I had to stop my car right that was the
first guy there and he had rolled over
on his back and I walked up to him and
he was just unconscious is going like
the funny part is when this cop finally
shows up the guy was like [ __ ] like
55 it's like shooting him retired by now
when did you start becoming a cop and
you're still driving a cruiser so he
pulls up and just completely could give
a [ __ ] he just walked up to the guy and
his hands in his pockets and he just
looked over me just goes
you all right
when I was a kid I don't know if you
ever saw this but there was a
some Christian Network back then not
there was nothing on TV there were a
couple of channels there was never
anything good on
and there was this show that we used to
watch that was made with uh sort of
claymation puppets called deviant
Goliath oh yeah and they always supposed
to have a good moral about how to behave
Davey was a boy who would sometimes do
naughty things and then he'd learn his
lesson and it was put out by some
Association of ministers I swear to God
my brothers and I would watch this
because there was you would flip the
channel and they're bowling on one
channel and there's a Catholic Mass on
the other channel and so you'd watch
Davey and Goliath because at least it
was a story and there was some
claymation anyway Davey
Tavian Goliath go camping with the dad
and the mom and Davey goes off and he
sees a well and or he sees a beautiful
natural pond and he finds some paint
some raspberry paint and he pours it
into the pond
turning it all right you know red and
the big bucket yeah huge butt was a
little little Pond and then he's
laughing he says
look Goliath I made a big thing of
raspberry goop and then the father comes
in and yells at him and says look what
you've done and all the animals are
gathered around and they can't drink
from this Pond anymore because it's been
ruined my brothers and I were laughing
so far
we were crying we were laughing so hard
I I'm telling you I understand exactly
what you're talking about he I think
these animals ended up dying
and my brothers and I are on the floor
laughing but Damian said look I made a
big thing of strawberry it's terrible
I'm sorry but there's no reason to
apologize they were claymation animals
oh there is like nobody does you know we
did you ever pour raspberry paint to a
pond no I saw that but if I had that you
can sit there and laugh you know what I
love is when Dave when Davey every once
in a while will get into a fight he
would get this [ __ ] kicked out of him
his because it was claymation it didn't
have the the money his hair was still
perfect and then they just put a couple
of strands of clay
to indicate that baby got his ass kicked
they have no idea what we're talking
about this the show was on 65 years ago
yeah but this is I'm trying to explain
our childhoods this is what it was like
back then there's nothing to watch
nothing to do and occasionally someone
in the house would lose their temper in
a way that would frighten you and then
it was never spoken about again yeah
yeah that was basically
that was it my brother I don't know if
I'd ever tell you this my brother was
like a genius man he used my parents
used to argue he had he had a a dual
cassette Boombox and he used to record
the argument and then put music
underneath
foreign
s ever was he put Led Zeppelin No
Quarter
which has this really John Paul Jones
places haunting keyboard it was right it
like it was scored perfectly because it
started off slow at them going back and
forth and then gradually and just Robert
Plant closed the door put out the lights
[Laughter]
bottoms drums
they came in my dad I [ __ ] down to get
the [ __ ] out of here
dude we used to listen to that [ __ ]
thing for like years and then we finally
played it for my dad and he laughed his
ass off I thought it was hilarious
he thought it was [ __ ] he never
understood anything we want Adam watched
the great Santini one time hoping that
he would get it and he didn't he ended
up just loving the movie and just
walking around going I am the great
Santana we're like no no it's about a
dad who's who's very abusive to his son
yeah who loves his family but doesn't
understand that he's slowly killing
everybody yeah yeah and your dad watched
that and thought thank you for showing
me oh he thought this uplifting film
about how we should all behave it was
like Sleepless in Seattle
When Harry Met Sally